Hablo de la compasión desde el punto de vista islámico,
y tal vez mi fe no sea vista
como una fe arraigada en la compasión.
La verdad es otra.
Nuestro libro sagrado, el Corán, consiste de 114 capítulos,
y cada capítulo comienza con lo que llamamos la basmala,
decimos: en el nombre de Dios, el Clemente y Misericordioso
o, como Sir Richard Burton,
no el Richard Burton que fue esposo de Elizabeth Taylor,
sino Sir Richard Burton, quien vivió un siglo antes,
viajó por todo el mundo
y fue traductor de muchas obras literarias,
él lo traduce como: "en el nombre de Dios, Graciabilísimo, Misericordiosísimo".
En un pasaje del Corán, que para los musulmanes es Dios que le habla a la Humanidad.
Dios dice a su profeta Mahoma,
quien creemos fue el último de un linaje de profetas,
comenzando con Adán, luego Noé, Moisés y Abrahán,
incluyendo Jesucristo, terminando con Mahoma
dijo: "No te enviamos, oh, Mahoma,
excepto como raham, como fuente de compasión para la Humanidad".
Para nosotros, como seres humanos, y como musulmanes,
cuya misión y propósito es seguir la senda del profeta,
debemos llegar a ser como el profeta
y el profeta dijo:
"Adórnense con los atributos divinos".
Porque Dios dijo que su principal atributo es la compasión,
de hecho, el Corán dice: "Dios se autoimpuso la compasión",
o "reinó sobre sí mediante la compasión".
Por tanto, tenemos el objetivo y la misión de ser fuentes de compasión,
activadores de la compasión, actores de la compasión,
voceros de la compasión, hacedores de la compasión.
Todo eso está bien,
pero ¿Dónde nos equivocamos,
y cuál es la causa de la falta de compasión en el mundo?
Para hallar la respuesta, acudimos a nuestra senda espiritual.
En cada tradición espiritual, existe una senda externa y una interna,
o la senda exotérica y la senda esotérica.
La senda esotérica del Islam se conoce como el sufismo, o tasawwuf en árabe.
Y todos estos doctores o maestros,
estos maestros espirituales de la tradición sufí,
se refieren a las enseñanzas y los ejemplos de nuestro profeta,
que nos enseñan adónde está la fuente de nuestros problemas.
En una de las batallas donde luchó nuestro profeta,
él dijo a sus seguidores: "Regresamos de una guerra menor
e iremos hacia una guerra mayor, la batalla mayor".
Y ellos dijeron: "Mensajero de Dios, estamos cansados de la batalla.
¿Cómo habríamos de ir a una batalla mayor?
Él dijo: "Esa es la batalla del ser, la batalla del ego".
Las fuentes de los problemas humanos se relacionan con el egoismo, el Yo.
El famoso maestro sufí, Rumi, muy conocido por ustedes,
cuenta una historia sobre un hombre que visita la casa de un amigo
toca la puerta,
y una voz responde: "¿Quién es?"
"Soy yo"
La voz dice: "Vete".
Después de muchos años de adiestramiento, disciplina y lucha,
él regresa,
y con mayor humildad, nuevamente toca la puerta.
La voz pregunta: "¿Quién es?"
Él responde: "Eres tú, oh, inconmovible".
La puerta se abre, y la voz dice:
"Entra, ya que no hay espacio en esta casa para dos "Yo",
2 yo (en inglés rima con eye), no 2 ojos (eyes), para 2 egos.
Las historias de Rumi son metáforas de la senda espiritual.
En presencia de Dios, no hay espacio para más de un Yo,
y ése es el Yo de la divinidad.
En una enseñanza llamada "hadith qudsi" en nuestra tradición,
Dios dice: "Mi siervo", o "mi criatura", mi criatura humana
no se aproxima a mí por ningún medio más preciado
que a través de aquéllo que le he pedido hacer".
Y los patronos saben bien lo que quiero decir.
Quieren que sus empleados hagan lo que pidan,
y si lo hacen, pueden hacer aún más,
pero no ignoran lo que ustedes les pidieron hacer.
Y Dios dice: "Mi siervo se acerca más a mí
al hacer más de lo que le he pedido".
ganando puntos extra, podríamos decir,
"haciéndome amarlo.
Y cuando amo a mi siervo", dice Dios,
Me transformo en los ojos por los que él o ella ve,
los oídos por los que escucha,
la mano con la que empuña,
el pie con que camina,
el corazón que le da entendimiento".
Ésta es la fusión de nuestro ser con la divinidad,
la lección y el fin de nuestra senda espiritual, de todas nuestras tradiciones de fe.
Los musulmanes ven a Jesús como el maestro del sufismo,
el más grande profeta y mensajero, que vino a resaltar la senda espiritual.
Cuando él dice: "Yo soy el Espíritu, Yo soy el camino",
cuando el profeta Mahoma dijo: "Quien me ha visto, ha visto a Dios",
es porque se han convertido en un instrumento de Dios,
son parte del hálito de Dios,
y así la voluntad de Dios se manifestó a través de ellos
ya que no actuaban desde sí mismos y desde su ego.
La compasión terrenal nos es dada, ya está en nosotros.
Todo lo que debemos hacer es retirar nuestros egos,
deshacernos de nuestro egoismo.
Estoy seguro de que todos ustedes, o la gran mayoría
han tenido una experiencia espiritual,
un momento de sus vidas en que, por unos segundos, tal vez un minuto,
los límites del ego se disolvieron.
Y durante ese minuto se sintieron uno con el Universo,
uno con esa jarra de agua, uno con cada ser humano.
uno con el creador,
y se sintieron en presencia del poder, del asombro,
del más profundo amor, la más profunda compasión y misericordia
que hayan experimentado en sus vidas.
Ese momento es un presente de Dios para nosotros,
un obsequio en que, por un momento, él retira esa barrera
que nos hace insistir en Yo, Yo, Yo,
y a cambio, como la persona en la historia de Rumi
decimos: "Oh, todo esto eres tú".
Todo esto eres tú. Y todo esto somos nosotros.
Y nosotros, y yo, y todos nosotros somos parte tuya.
Creador de todas las cosas, todos los fines, la fuente de nuestro ser,
y el final de nuestra travesía.
También eres quien rompe nuestros corazones.
Eres aquél a quien debemos dirigirnos, aquél por quien vivimos,
y aquél por quien habremos de morir,
y por quien habremos de resucitar
para justificar ante Dios cuán compasivos hemos sido.
Hoy nuestro mensaje y propósito,
y quienes están hoy aquí,
y el propósito de este capítulo de compasión, es recordar.
Y es que el Corán siempre nos urge recordar, que nos recordemos,
porque el conocimiento de la verdad está en cada ser humano.
Sabemos todo.
Tenemos acceso a todo.
Jung lo llamó el inconsciente.
A través de nuestro inconsciente, en nuestros sueños,
lo que el Corán llama, estar durmiendo, la muerte menor,
la muerte temporal.
Cuando dormimos, soñamos, tenemos visiones,
incluso muchos viajamos fuera de nuestros cuerpos,
y vemos cosas maravillosas.
Viajamos más allá de las limitaciones del espacio, tal como lo conocemos,
y más allá de las limitaciones del tiempo, tal como lo conocemos.
Pero todo esto es para glorificar el nombre del creador
cuyo nombre primordial es el Clemente, el Compasivo.
Dios, Bokh, como deseen llamarlo, Alá, Ram, Om,
sea cual fuere el nombre que usen para denotar
o llegar a la presencia de la divinidad,
es el locus del ser absoluto,
amor, piedad y compasión absolutos,
conocimiento y sabiduría absolutos,
lo que los hindúes llaman satchidananda.
El lenguaje puede cambiar,
pero el objetivo es el mismo.
Hay otra historia de Rumi
de tres personajes: un turco, un árabe,
y olvido el tercero, pero podría ser un malayo.
Uno pide angour, el otro es, digamos, un británico,
uno pide eneb, y el otro pide uvas.
Y pelean y discuten porque
Yo quiero uvas, yo quiero eneb, yo quiero angour,
sin saber que la palabra que usan
se refiere a la misma realidad en diferentes idiomas.
Sólo hay una realidad absoluta por definición,
un solo ser absoluto por definición,
porque lo absoluto es, por definición, único,
absoluto y singular.
Hay una concentración absoluta del ser,
la absoluta concentración de la conciencia,
la cognición, un locus absoluto de compasión y amor
que define los atributos divinos primordiales.
Y ésos también deben ser
los principales atributos de lo que significa la humanidad.
Ya que lo que define a humanidad, tal vez de manera biológica,
es nuestra fisiología,
pero Dios define a la humanidad por nuestra espiritualidad y naturaleza.
El Corán dice, él habló a los ángeles y dijo:
"Cuando termine de formar a Adán con arcilla,
e insufle en él mi espíritu,
entonces póstrense ante él".
Los ángeles se postraron, no ante el cuerpo humano,
sino ante el alma humana.
¿Por qué? Porque el alma, el alma humana,
encarna parte del hálito divino,
parte del alma divina.
Esto también se expresa en el vocabulario bíblico
cuando nos enseñan que fuimos creados en semenjanza a la imagen divina.
¿Cuál es la imaginería de Dios?
La imaginería de Dios es el ser absoluto,
cognición, conocimiento y sabiduría absolutos,
amor y compasión absolutos.
Entonces, para que seamos humanos,
en el más alto sentido de lo que significa ser humano,
en el más gozoso sentido de lo que significa ser humano,
quiere decir que también nosotros debemos ser facilitadores
del hálito divino que yace en nosotros,
y buscar perfeccionar en nosotros el atributo del ser,
de estar vivos, de nuestra condición de ser,
el atributo de la sabiduría, consciencia, cognición,
y el atributo de ser seres compasivos y amorosos.
Esto es lo que entiendo de la tradición de mi fe,
y esto es lo que entiendo de mis estudios de otras tradiciones de fe,
ésta es la plataforma común que todos debemos pisar,
y cuando pisemos esta plataforma
estoy convencido de que podremos crear un mundo maravilloso.
Y creo, personalmente, que estamos cerca,
y con la presencia y ayuda de personas como ustedes,
podemos hacer realidad la profecía de Isaías.
Él predijo una era
en la que la gente transformará sus espadas en arados
y no aprenderán la guerra, y ya no librarán la guerra.
Hemos llegado a una etapa de la historia humana donde no hay opción.
Debemos aplacar nuestros egos,
controlar nuestros egos, sea el ego individual, personal,
el ego familiar, el ego nacional,
y que todo sea por glorificar el uno.
Gracias, y que Dios los bendiga.
(Aplausos)